quand on voit les femmes qui parfois
recueille que seuls les mégots ou
d'autres détails comme ça des cantons et
idolâtre quelqu'un et surtout que je me
trouvais dans les coulisses de bercy
l'accord hôtel arena et que je je je je
vois sortir des toilettes mick jagger me
giguère
bon je vous le dis en vigueur mais je
garde du merlu je le vois sortir des
toilettes ya de ça quelques années et je
me suis dit il a comme j'ai envie de
pisser je suis rentré quand même voie et
j'ai vu qu'à vider des petites crottes
qui flotte des voiliers et je me suis
dit c'est sûrement lui donc je vais
essayer d'en piquer une étoile revendre
sur bon quoi
non ça passe à la trappe et ben oui mais
on est vraiment fait ça m et ben c'est
dégueulasse non 4 à réfléchir j'ai été
plongé le supposer que c'était les
crottes de mick jagger c'est énorme
comme mais en fait c'étaient des codes
de roger bouchard - dès que ça c'est sûr
en festival il y avait la rappeuse nicki
minaj et je me suis faufilé dans sa loge
elle venait de partir j'ai pris sa
brosse à dents dans sa loge tout était
rose en fait j'ai pris ça pour ça dans
l'horreur qu'elle est encore chez moi je
me brosser les dents avec quelle horreur
est ce que tu sais ce qu'elle avait sur
la joue pas non mais je leur ai tout cas
on sait ce qu'il a fait mick jagger
c'est donc cette histoire franchement et
donc c'est vrai je voulais vraiment
écouter pour vous